playing the Matt wall show it seems that
every week the left invents a new hero
that we're all supposed to worship and
admire but their latest Heroes the
so-called Tennessee three are
performance artists nearly as phony and
fraudulent as Dylan Mulvaney a viral
video reveals just how fake these people
actually are also the Governor of
Tennessee pushes for uh so-called red
flag laws I'll explain why red flag laws
are a horrible idea and Bud Light takes
a four billion dollar hit after it
endorsed transgenderism uh plus a new
report suggests that over sixty thousand
babies will be saved this year because
of the overturn of Roe yet the left
treats this as bad news even worse some
on the right seem to agree with them
we'll talk about all that and much more
today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
are you struggling to find time to
incorporate fruits and vegetables into
your diet with busy schedules and
on-the-go Lifestyles it's easy to
overlook the importance of these
nutrient-packed Foods however eating
fruits and vegetables is crucial for
maintaining good health and well-being
even when life gets hectic and that's
why I'm a huge fan of balance of nature
bounce of nature fruits and vegetables
are a great way to make sure you're
getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day their
capsules are packed with 100 whole food
you can take at any time balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural antioxidants and
16 whole fruits and 15 whole vegetables
and encapsulates them for easy
consumption fruits and vegetables are
loaded with vitamins minerals fiber and
antioxidants that are essential for your
health
they can help boost your immune system
improve digestion reduce inflammation
and lower the risk of chronic disease
such as heart disease diabetes and
cancer so make fruits and vegetables a
part of your daily diet with balance of
nature your body will thank you right
now balance of nature is offering 35 off
with your first preferred order go to
bouncenature.com use promo code Walsh
for 35 off that's balanced nature.com
promo code Welsh
as we've seen the left is very good at
creating Heroes and that's not to say
that leftism as an ideology drives
people to engage in heroic Acts or
inspires them towards heroic virtue
obviously that's not the case quite the
quite the opposite uh rather they're
Adept at inventing Heroes making them
fabricating them out of whole cloth they
can simply assign somebody the role of
hero put them on a platform and instruct
the rest of us to praise and admire them
you know every society needs its Heroes
as Champions it's Martyrs but our
traditional heroes in in our culture
have all been torn down literally in
many cases as statues and monuments have
been toppled and now they're replaced by
these new constructions and the trouble
with our new Heroes the ones at the left
constructs for us is that they are
shallow contrived empty and usually
morally repulsive so one one relevant
example from this week Megan rapino
speaking of repulsive female soccer
player has long been elevated to the
position of Heroes she's she's
courageous because when she's not being
beaten on the field by high school boys
she's busy fighting for women's rights
or so we're told she's a big proponent
of equal pay you know she spent many
years raising awareness about the plight
of underpaid female soccer players
rappino herself is wealthy but she could
be a little more wealthy if only she was
paid the same as male soccer stars now
granted male soccer stars make more
money because they uh bring in more
money because the public is just more
interested in in you know seeing men
play soccer and male Sports in general
because they're more fun to watch
because the athletes are better but this
argument was not acceptable it's a rap
you know who insisted that her pay as a
soccer player should be uh not at all
tied to her financial worth as a soccer
player and eventually that argument won
out and the men's and women's U.S
national team signed an agreement uh
that that agree that there would be
equal pay which really just means that
the men's team will have to be
essentially the sugar daddies for the
women's team
subsidizing and keeping this equal pay
scheme afloat because that's what female
empowerment is all about apparently but
of course the real threat facing women's
sports is not that athletes are
underpaid it's that if the left has its
way women's sports will effectively
cease to exist as a category in the
first place you're not going to make any
money as a female athlete because there
won't be female sports and this is where
the actual heroes are needed to speak up
and stand against the intrusion of males
into women's sports yet faced with this
actual threat to women's sports and the
rights of women generally the heroic
Rapinoe surrendered immediately without
even pretending to put up a fight
just like most other athletes did this
week Rapinoe joined a number of other
professional athletes and signing a
letter
condemning legislation that's been
proposed by republicans in Congress that
would ban males from competing in female
sports Sports Illustrated reports quote
a group of 40 professional Olympic and
paralympic athletes signed a letter
regarding recent anti-trans Sports ban
sent to the house representative
legislative directors on Monday the
athletes include uh Megan rapino
recently retired WNBA star Sue bird and
a US wnt star Becky sauerbrun
the remaining athletes were who signed
the letter organized by the lgbtq
advocacy group athlete Ally compete in
various Sports such as soccer hockey and
rugby the letter calls out the
republican-led protection of girls and
women in sports act H.R 734 which would
ban transgender intersex girls and women
from competing in sports across the
country if the bill passes it will
become part of the Title IX legislation
and explaining our stance wrapping out
tweeted quote today politicians of DC
are claiming to protect women's sports
by pushing a trans and intersex Sports
ban call your Congressional rep today to
say women's sports needs protection from
unequal pay sexual abuse and lack of
resources not from trans kids now
needless to say the claims made here are
total nonsense there are no bills that
would ban trans-identify people from
competing in sports uh there are
certainly no bills that would ban
intersex people people with uh with
genital defects from competing in sports
not one piece of proposed Federal
legislation not one bill passed or
proposed in any state has ever had any
language that would prohibit anyone from
competing in sports based on their
so-called quote-unquote gender identity
I wouldn't support such legislation if
it was introduced although it never
would be
because I don't see any particular
reason why a man who sees himself as a
woman should be prevented from playing
football or basketball or running on the
track team or whatever if he wants but
his quote unquote gender identity should
not be some kind of special token that
he can use to gain access to whatever
team he prefers male should compete
against males females against females
and um that's what these bills
guaranteed translated identified people
can still compete but they have to
compete against their own sex same as
everyone else that's what that's what
equal under the law actually means Megan
Rapinoe the supposed champion of women's
sports opposes this policy which means
that she supports the erosion and
eventual demise of women's sports
entirely
and that's not because she actually
believes that male athletes who identify
as women really are women
and and should be allowed on women's
sport she doesn't really believe that
she doesn't think that she almost
certainly doesn't believe it because
almost nobody born before the year of
say 2005 sincerely believes that trans
ideology is true few of us were
brainwashed early enough to actually
believe it
if you want to get someone to believe
something that insane you have to get to
them when they're very young which is
why the left is so focused on getting to
the kids when they're very young with
this stuff
but rap you know like
every other leftist goes along with it
because she thinks that it helps further
her overall ideological agenda and also
because she lacks the courage it would
require to take a stand in this case it
would legitimately be heroic for
somebody in her position
to defend common sense and reality
in this case shouldn't be it shouldn't
require heroism but it would because
she'd be ripped apart for it excoriated
she'd lose all of her friends and clout
and media praise and she's not going to
be invited on late night shows you're
talking about on any red carpets anymore
um takes heroism to make that kind of
sacrifice and if there's one thing that
this hero lacks it's heroism
but there are other fake leftist heroes
in the news this week in fact just in
the last couple of weeks we've watched
as three new ones have been invented in
real time so very efficiently the quote
unquote Tennessee three as the media has
dubbed them have been celebrated
basically deified after getting kicked
out of the Tennessee State House for
state house for staging and Insurrection
in the Capitol building on Monday one of
them Justin Jones was sworn back in
after the Nashville metropolitan council
did an end run around Republicans in the
legislature by voting to reinstate him
as now an interim uh representative for
the 52nd District so he's back in the
house which means that by the way
Republicans now
have no choice really but to pass a law
Banning anyone who's expelled from the
house from serving again in state
government they could pass that law and
they need to and then once it's passed
expel him again
they have to play hardball here or else
take the loss
and taking the loss can never be an
option
yeah it would be a big it's a big you're
taking a big loss if you take it here
because then you will have uh you will
have given this guy all this attention
turn him into a martyr
uh only to have them back in in the the
legislature anyway at the end of it
can't allow that can't allow it
but even if but even if they're both
reinstated one of them was never
expelled to begin with that's not going
to change their status as Heroes and
martyrs as far as the left concerned
once the left has deemed you as such as
a hero and a martyr you cannot lose that
title except
by taking a position they disagree with
and there's little chance of that
happening with this crew um one of the
Tennessee three former representative
Justin Pearson
has especially embraced his uh his
Newfound fake hero status in fact
Pearson has reinvented himself totally
um in both look and speech as some sort
of 1960s era civil rights figure
that is um
a civil rights figure from the 1960s who
happens to speak the gibberish of 21st
century leftism so for example here is
Pearson just last week delivering a
sermon at a Memphis Unitarian
Universalist Church
in case you aren't familiar maybe you
don't know all the denominations of
Christianity what you should know about
unitary universalists is that it is not
a denomination of Christianity it's just
a fancy way of saying Satanist
um as you can clearly see in this clip
watch well y'all I was glad when they
said unto me let us go into the house of
the Lord I'm so glad to be in the house
of the Lord with you this morning would
you mind going ahead and praying with me
now mother God create a God loving God
holy God take this your servant made
from dust and connected with the raw
materials of Stardust to speak in this
moment to say something that brings
forward the word you've placed into my
heart I accept my unworthiness for such
a task as bold as this and I seek your
guidance as you use me and speak through
me to the ancestor preachers who made
sermons from hymns moans and groans and
spirituals from the bondage of slavery
speak now through this your descendant
yeah it's very interesting because he
begins by trying to speak you know like
a Biblical prophet in King James version
of the Old Testament uh but then he
quickly transitions from Biblical
Prophet to a middle-aged white woman
reading tarot cards babbling about
mother God and saying something about
how we're all connected by the raw
material of Stardust
essentially if uh it's like if a yoga
instructor from San Francisco went back
in time to the year 85 BC this is what
he would sound like
it's bizarre and it's unintentionally
hilarious but but we do have to cut
Pearson some slack here after all he
just invented this Persona recently he's
still working out the Kinks he hasn't he
hasn't learned all the lines yet uh and
and that's it's not fair for any actor
to just expect them to drop them into a
role and they're gonna nail it on the
first try it takes some practice and
he's still practicing and we know that
this is a recent Persona Forum because
there's a video comparison that maybe
you've seen if you haven't I'll show it
to you it's been making the rounds on
social media I don't know who first put
this together but it's brilliant because
it just
shows you
and illustrates
um how fraudulent these people are so
we've seen the video Justin Pearson of
2016 when he was a a young eager college
student and then uh we could compare him
to Justin Pearson of last week
what's here's what that comparison
sounds like
Dustin J Pearson and I'm running for
president of BSG there are a few reasons
that we're running this campaign this
year one has to do with representation
how can we represent all voices in a
conversation I wanted to do this by
partnering with organizations from the
voting Democrats to the Buddha
Republicans I want to bring together
different voices dissenting voices
voices that may be more liberal or more
conservative in order that we can reach
a point of sort of the radical middle
seem like
[Music]
along this Saturday in the state of
Tennessee might last but oh we have good
news folks we've got good news that
Sunday always comes
um
you know he doesn't he doesn't really
sound like a 1960s civil rights figure
which is what he's trying to sound like
and look like uh he sounds like he's
doing a parody of one you know this is
this is the worst case of blackface that
we've seen since Justin Trudeau except
that Pearson's actually black and he's
still doing blackface
nevertheless he is performing
and we know he's performing because now
we know what he sounded like before the
performance started
it's not at all a convincing performance
of course
in fact I didn't think I'd see a
performance less convincing than Dylan
Mulvaney's portrayal of Womanhood until
Pearson came along Pearson's really
given a run for his money
this is what the left promotes and
encourages empty performance
taken to comical almost surreal extremes
you know they give us Heroes and leaders
who are cartoons
who are Hollow and paper thin who are it
always turns out conniving cowards
gutless frauds and self-aggrandizing
performance artists that's what all
these people are
and yet we're meant to applaud these
people
but the only appropriate response is to
laugh in their faces and dismiss
everything they say
now let's get to our five headlines
foreign
[Music]
companies it's proudly veteran-owned
employs a us-based customer service team
and absolutely refuses to spend money on
fake news networks here's a look at what
a future without Pure Talk would look
like for you for those of you who can't
see what's playing out on the screen
right now I am currently texting with my
producer Sean on a phone that's serviced
by one of the big three wireless
networks Sean says have you seen the
post about the left trying to cancel you
again which I reply in this very real
conversation they're always trying to
silence me and it's never going to work
because that's the kind of thing that I
would say in a text message you know in
real life I would text that to someone
when are people going to accept that men
or men and women are women only
autocorrect changes men to MXN and women
to wom xn if you can believe it this is
what you get with Welk Wireless
Uninvited lessons and political
correctness if there's anyone I trust to
not only give me the best service for my
money but also not try to force their
Politics on me it's pure talk no
contracts no hassle and they respect
your politics right now you can get
unlimited talk text and plenty of 5G
data for just thirty dollars a month
keep your phone keep your number or
choose from the latest iPhones and
Androids go to puretalk.com enter promo
code Walsh to save an additional 50 off
your first month that's puretalk.com
promo code walls sure talk is simply
smarter Wireless report from the daily
wire Governor Bill Lee called for
Tennessee's Republican majority
legislature to pass a red flag law
Tuesday after signing an executive order
strengthening the state's background
checks on firearm buyers the new push
comes two weeks after three children
three adults were murdered at the
Covenant School in Nashville when a
trans-identifying shooter made her way
into the Christian School and gunned
down students and staff Lee told The
Tennessean that he's asking the general
assembly to bring forward an order of
protection law also known as a red flag
law which would enable the government to
take Firearms away from those who are
found to be at risk to themselves or
others
the governor said quote a new strong
order of protection law will provide the
broader population cover safety from
those who are a danger to themselves or
the population This is Our Moment to
lead and to give the people of Tennessee
what they deserve Lee's executive order
creates a 72-hour period of any for any
new criminal activity and Court mental
health information to be reported on the
Tennessee instant check system the
background check system used by the
Tennessee Bureau of Investigation under
the order the TBI is required to tell
Lee's office in the general assembly
within two months of any barriers to
complete accurate and timely reporting
of information that is accessible to the
tics
red flag laws which are on the books in
19 States including republican-led
States uh like Indiana and Florida
specifically Target those deemed to have
mental health issues and allow a state
court to issue an order for law
enforcement to confiscate weapons from
those ruled to be at risk
the 28 year old Covenant School shooter
who stockpiled seven Firearms was
receiving treatment for an emotional
disorder according to Nashville police
and her parents did not want her to own
guns but she did opponents of red flag
laws say that they pose a threat to
Second Amendment rights and due process
and do not prevent criminal acts
um
yeah I'm well count me among the
opponents very much so I don't I don't
like red flags laws at all I understand
the idea behind them I understand the
logic you know the logic is well you've
got crazy people with guns you take
their guns away but I think it's bad
logic
and for a few reasons the first is is
it's the Constitutional issue the
constitutional rights that are at stake
here and it's not it's not first the
second amendment that goes because of
red flag laws it's due the due process
it's our constitutional right to due
process that goes out the window with
red flag laws and then uh the Second
Amendment is next so both of them are
put in Jeopardy in a big way
because
according to the rights who are
guaranteed in the Constitution you can't
deprive somebody
of their rights you can't deprive them
of their uh property without without due
process of law
and so yes if somebody's convicted of a
violent crime then you T well they
should be in prison so of course they're
not gonna have any guns
so if there's someone who's who's done
something
um which would warrant that then you
charge and convict them of it
that's that's what that's what the law
is supposed to be
yeah that's almost all of our you know
rights can be taken away that's like
when you go to prison almost every right
that you have is now has now been um at
the very least constricted
to a great degree
because you've committed a crime and
you've proven yourself to be uh you know
a a member of society that we can't
trust to be out in society and so we got
to put you in a cage and so that means a
lot of the rights of the rest of us
enjoy you're not going to enjoy it one
of them obviously is the Second
Amendment you're not going to bring a
gun into prison
um but you have to actually convict
somebody of the crime first
and
the reason why this is so important is
to just due process in general is very
important it's one of the most essential
uh legal rights that we have
but also I don't trust the system
to decide who is mentally fit to carry
firearms I don't trust them to decide
that
okay we're leaving up to the system to
say well yeah this person hasn't hasn't
committed a crime yet so now it's like a
Minority Report you know pre-crime thing
hasn't committed a crime yet but we
think based on their based on uh certain
mental red flags psychiatric red flags
we think that they will
well that to support something like that
displays an awful lot of trust in the
system
trust their judgment
uh trust that they're not ever going to
abuse this power
you know trust that we're that there's
going to be somehow wide agreement about
what constitutes
you know a a psychiatric red flag
and I don't trust that at all
I mean they've already look they've
already set the stage
they will tell you outright okay the
left will tell you outright that if you
oppose them on really anything but in
particular if you oppose them on quote
unquote trans rights uh or anything in
the you know anything having to do with
LGBT if you oppose that then um you're
you're wrong you're genocidal
you're violent like these are violent
just to have that point of view is an
act of violence the quote unquote
misgender someone is an act of violence
so that's what they consider the red
flags to be
it it's
not going to be long before some judge
somewhere says well this person's a
transphobe
and that's uh in effect a mental illness
and they're already engaging in violence
and there's very good chance that
they're gonna you know go out and try to
kill trans people and we know that based
on the fact that they're misgendering
all the time we got to take their guns
away it's it will not be long until
something like that happens
um
and actually if you again if you ask the
left I bet you they'll they'll tell you
that out you know ask any ask ask any
leftists what do you think do you think
transphobes should be allowed to have
second amendment rights
most every single one of them would say
of course not
and then also this is happening in the
context of a society where we've got
this psychiatric industry that's turning
everything into a mental illness that's
we we're seeing that happen right now
everything is being turned the
diagnostic Cisco manual mental disorders
expands with each new addition and
they're constantly finding you know
labeling other new aspects of the human
condition as mental illnesses
and already
pretty much any emotion thought Behavior
could be a symptom of mental illness
anyone I mean literally anyone
can be diagnosed with a mental illness
you know anyone can go there's there's
not anyone alive who uh who would not be
labeled mentally ill in about seven
different ways according to the DSM as
it stands right now
so are we comfortable with that
as they as they uh catalog the entire
human condition as you know nothing but
a series of mental illness symptoms are
we are we comfortable saying that also
if you have a mental illness they can
take your guns away
I'm certainly not
another report from the bat from uh the
daily wire and more bad news
unfortunately in Tennessee says well
over 100 Tennessee residents flooded the
city of Franklin late Tuesday afternoon
ahead of a city board meeting over
approval of a gay pride festival in a
vote of five to four the Franklin City
Board voted to allow a pride festival to
proceed after a marathon board meeting
that lasted nearly five hours the board
was split with a vote of four to four
but Franklin mayor Ken Moore cast the
deciding vote even after acknowledging
that the event last year was not family
friendly his decision was met with
cheers from outside the boardroom
for the past two years Franklin a city
just south of Nashville has posted a
pride hosted a pride festival which
residents and City board members say has
exposed children to inappropriate drag
performances and other indecencies one
drag queen president the 2022 Festival
went by the name Blair
um
which is when it comes to drag queens
and the names that they choose
themselves that's that's on the Tamer
end of the spectrum because very often
they choose names that are that are very
sexually explicit because the whole
thing is supposed to be sexual
um dozens of people crammed into a small
hearing room with a good number of
individuals wearing stickers that read
protect all children While others wore
rainbow themed shirts
[Music]
um
and there are people speaking on both
sides of it
um
one student from Spring Hill who said
that she identified as transgender
claimed that Transit fi people were
being hunted on a national level so a
lot of that sort of thing and that
argument won out
you know we keep hearing from the LGBT
left that um
Banning
Banning them from sexualizing children
Banning them from prancing around half
naked in front of children is the same
as Banning their very existence and
that's what they're keeping that's what
they keep telling us
you pass the laws that say you can't you
can't do this in front of children you
can't you know expose children to this
kind of inappropriate content
if you do that we're told we're Banning
them we're trying to erase them as LGBT
people and I'm just wondering
at what point
do we simply believe these people I mean
at what point do we take their word for
it
take them at their word
they are the ones telling us
that if you pass a law prohibiting
children from being involved in sexually
explicit activities that will be a
burden on them because according to them
apparently sexualizing children is a big
you know is a big part of being an LGBT
activist that's what they are saying
and if they didn't believe that about
themselves then they would simply say
you know they would simply say oh we
can't have drag shows for kids we can't
we can't have kids sit and watch male
Cabaret performers or female you know we
can't have kids go up and give them
money like they're at a strip club we
can't invite children to gay clubs okay
no problem obviously we don't want to do
that okay no no issue I mean we're
offended that you think you even need a
law like that
they could say that
that's what they could say
but they don't instead they say what we
can't dance half naked in front of kids
well well that means we can't have any
gay pride celebrations at all it's such
a big part of what we do
well okay guys
if
if that's what it means they're saying
that's what it means and that's what it
means
but it is you saying that
maybe you should stop and think about
that
you know because all the law here in
Tennessee and other places that have
passed similar laws
none of them single out LGBT
they don't even single out drag
specifically they just say look you
can't sexual content sexual activities
in front of kids not appropriate you
can't do that
it's wrong
you know and that applies to everyone
but everybody else have you noticed this
if you're LGBT activist have you noticed
that everyone else in society when we
hear this and there are rules and laws
passed all the rest of us are like yeah
fine of course
yeah that's that's that's not uh you
know you're not you're not cramping our
style at all with with laws like that
because we have no interest in engaging
in that activity you are the ones
who recoil into horror at the thought
that children can't be sexualized so you
know maybe you should think about that
now of course in Franklin
um
they can still go forward with these
kinds of activities because of the
cowardice of the City Board
which is the story there
's another episode of headline versus
reality here's the headline
and this is a headline from uh
let's see which one uh there's a
headline from Forbes I think
Idaho becomes first the first state to
restrict Interstate travel for abortion
now you've probably seen headlines like
this circulating every news organization
has a version of this story about Idaho
uh that Idaho is preventing people from
leaving the state for abortions
but here's the reality though and you'll
see the reality if you actually click on
the link to these articles and you read
the article then you will they will tell
you the the rest of the story but they
know that most people don't read the
articles most people don't click on the
links all they see is the headlines so
if you you know you can effectively bury
something
um just by you can you can bury it and
report it at the same time and these
news organizations know that
because they could put something in the
article and then say what do you mean we
didn't bury it we put it right there
yeah but you knew that no one's going to
read it so you made a misleading
headline that has the rest of it in the
story but no one reads the story well if
you read the rest of the story here's
what it says
Idaho's Governor signed a law this week
making it illegal for an adult to
transport a minor to get an abortion
without their parents consent making
Idaho the first state to limit
Interstate travel for abortion
oh okay so it's illegal
to bring a child across state lines for
an abortion without their parents
consent
um so in other words you cannot secretly
traffic a child to an out-of-state
abortion clinic without even telling the
parents
you can't do that
who who could possibly oppose a law like
that well I know I mean
people who are demonic
which unfortunately describes uh
essentially one half of the political
ideological Spectrum at this point
but you you would have to be demonic to
to oppose something like that
because what's the other so you actually
think so you think
that it should be legal for some adult
to take a child without telling their
parents
to another state
for an abortion which even
you would call if you're a pro-abortion
you'd call abortion a medical procedure
which it isn't because medical
procedures by definition are meant to
treat and heal cure you know that's what
medical procedures do they treat
illnesses and diseases and injuries well
pregnancy is not an illness a disease or
treat or or you know an injury so it's
not a medical treatment but but let's
just go with that fantasy world for a
second where it's a medical treatment
would you
would that even be appropriate
an adult so this is not your child
you're bringing someone else's child to
another state for a quote-unquote
medical treatment without telling the
parents
I mean I can't think of a of a scenario
where we appropriate for an adult to
bring a child across state lines without
the parents consent for anything
I don't care what you do I don't care if
you're going to uh you're taking across
the state lines to go to Arby's like
there's no scenario where that would be
okay if the parents don't know about it
or have or or in fact have said no
if if the parents said no you can't
bring my kids to Arby's and uh you know
you can't you can't drive down to
Minnesota to go to Arby's
well to go anyway that's like kidnapping
and that's if you're just going to
Arby's but in this case we're not
talking about that are we
um
so this is something
that even if you supported
the murder of children
uh you should still support a law like
this because to not support it is to say
that it's okay for adults to bring kids
or not their kids to other states
without without with while the parents
either don't know or are actively
objecting to it
staying on this topic for just a second
Bloomberg has this report in the six
months since the U.S Supreme Court
overturned Roe v Wade there were 5 377
fewer abortions on average per month
according to a new report the average
number of terminations from July through
December was uh seventy seven thousand
seven percent drop from the average in
April and May according to a Tuesday
report from the Society of family
planning
so
that's uh that works out to about over
60 000 babies that were saved you know
that's over 60 000 babies who are gonna
be born rather than killed and um
like we talked about a minute ago you
know needing to look at yourself in the
mirror and think about your own
positions and what kind of person you
become uh well this is another occasion
for that because if you hear
that sixty thousand babies were not
killed and are going to be born instead
and you're sad about that yeah if what I
just read to you if that if that to you
is a is a sad headline
then that should tell you something very
troubling about yourself in the state of
your own soul
and this should also show us if people
on the right too because that you know
there have been conservatives that have
lamented
um
have lamented really that that row was
overturned and that these laws are being
passed in States because they think that
it hurts Republicans uh you know
um at The Ballot Box I think it hurts
them politically they think it hurts on
an electoral level
and I'm not fully convinced by that
first of all that's a separate
discussion
we don't even need to talk about that
because let's just say for the sake of
argument let's agree that there is an
electoral price that's being paid
because of this
um as as all of the baby murder
enthusiasts are just are
driven insane in their satanic rage and
they're driven to go to the the to the
polls and vote against Republicans who
want to save babies so let's just say
that's the case
is it not worth the price so do we even
have to talk about this
saving already sixty thousand babies is
that not
is that not worth it
if we're saying it's not worth it then
what the hell are we doing I thought
this is the end is the end goal simply
political power for its own sake just to
have it
the whole point of political power is to
do something with it
okay I'm not impressed it doesn't make
me uh sleep easy at night just to know
that there are Republicans in power at
least people with ours next to their
name are in power I don't care about
that I want them to use the power
the only reason I want Republicans in
power is on is on the the the
faint hope that they'll do something
with it
but you have you have conservatives who
apparently their position is
um we can't have Republicans do anything
to enact their agenda because then that
means they won't be elected
uh and we really want them to get
elected
but we don't want them to do anything
when they are
well then what the hell is the point
this to me call me crazy but saving 60
000 babies in a year yeah that's worth
that's worth taking a dip in the polls I
would say
all right um
a couple other things
so I want to mention this we've had some
bad news here's some good news well that
was what we just read was was really
good news uh so we've had two pieces of
of bad news then one good news here's
another piece of good news
um American beer brand Bud Light knocked
four billion dollars off of its parent
company anheuser-busch's market cap this
past past week following a
pro-transgender advertisement featuring
the biological male nose known as Dylan
Mulvaney
on March 31st Anheuser-Busch had a
market capitalization of
132.38 billion dollars by April 10th the
figure had dropped to 128 billion uh uh
28.4 billion with signs of the stock
market will continue to fall
um
and uh so and we know that this is all
happening after
uh
they had this endorsement deal with
Dylan Mulvaney and some conservatives
spoke out against it
and this is great this is a great thing
and we need to keep it up
yeah the only negative here is the
possibility that we won't
keep it up this will just be a blip on
the radar screen
and then and then conservatives will
just go back to buying Bud Light again
as long as we don't make that mistake
then this is a big win
as long as we stick with it it's not
hard to do
like you cut Bud Light out of your life
in a second
and it requires requires no effort and
you'll be fine like even if you like
that kind of terrible beer there are
other types that are just as cheap and
um
that you can choose instead but you know
I see conservatives sometimes
complaining that this has been a big
thing on Twitter and on social media you
have something servers complaining the
right shouldn't have focused on this Bud
Light thing as much as it's a
distraction they say and in general they
say we shouldn't be talking about Dylan
Mulvaney because uh you know by talking
about him we've quote unquote made him
famous right like he's a he's a he is a
a monster of our own making is the logic
but that's a really lazy take and it's
and it's it's obtuse
and it's not correct
okay just like we talked about in the
open the left appoints their own Heroes
they're champions
this is what they do the left selected
Mulvaney as their mascot for
transgenderism their new mascot he's
gonna be famous no matter what we did
that's how this works if you haven't
noticed by now
the left doesn't need our help to make
someone famous they can do that all on
their own they own all of the
institutions that bestow Fame in the
first place so you think they need us to
go along with it
we could never say a word about someone
they'd still be made into a star I mean
look at uh look at Stacey Abrams
for example the right has never had any
kind of obsession with Stacy Abrams we
we've we've never found her particularly
interesting or talked about her very
much
uh when she runs for office obviously
but you know I don't think anyone could
accuse anyone on the right of having a
Stacy Abrams uh Obsession and and also
she's just she has no Charisma she has
no star power she's just like a big
nothing
and yet the left selected her they said
you're we're gonna make your you know
you're one of our mascots you're one of
our you're one of ours now you're you're
a star we're gonna we've decided we've
decided that you're a star and the next
thing you know she's doing TV uh cameos
and she's on all the late night shows
she's on red carpet she's going to award
shows she's you know she's uh so she's
hanging out with celebrities
and all of that happened without any of
us on the right contributing to it
because again
they own all the institutions that
bestow Fame
we could I so when when Mulvaney comes
along we can either
nod and go along silently
while the next Woman face Minstrel show
star is appointed or we can speak up and
we can State what is true and obvious
remember Philip mulvania that that thing
at the in New York the the day 365 of
the big Gala Celebration Day 365 of
quote-unquote girlhood and again
celebrities were there it was a big well
remember he started planning that
six months into his girlhood schtick
so he started planning that that was on
in the the cards before most people on
the right even took note of this guy
he already had all this funding and
support and this is already planned all
of it
um and so when they when they bring in a
parade another man around it says the
woman look how great this was a woman of
the new woman of the year we have two
choices on the right we can either just
look the other way
or we can speak up and say no this is
absurd this is wrong here's why
some of us chose the latter and the
latter is the better choice
now here's the thing
we can't make Dylan Mulvaney unfamous
once the left has decided to do that
with someone we can't stop it we don't
own Hollywood we don't own the media
um
but we can
make someone a much more toxic and
divisive figure than he otherwise would
have been and that's what we did with
Dylan Mulvaney and it was well deserved
we can't make them unfamous we can
to use a leftist term problematize him
this is the term the left uses so to
literally like to make to take something
that's not seen as a problem and make it
a problem
a similar thing was successfully
achieved with uh with the Hershey's dude
a few weeks ago it's a necessary tactic
in the culture War it's very necessary
and the tactic in this case is simply to
say what is true so but we are
problematizing by pointing to an actual
problem the left problematizes by making
something a problem that isn't the
problem
but we're taking something that is a
problem which in this case is the
degradation appropriation of Womanhood
and we're pointing out that no this is a
problem here's why
um
and because of that you know Bud Light
took a major hit
and again that if if we go back on it
then it doesn't mean anything it's not a
win
but if we stick with it
then I guarantee you the next the next
corporation that serves a similar
customer base to the to what Bud Light
serves we'll think twice
before doing an endorsement with Dylan
Mulvaney or anybody like that they'll
think twice about they might still do it
but we've given them something to think
about is it really worth it
all right finally NBC News has this
report President Joe Biden has chosen
Chicago as the site of the 2024
Democratic National Convention staking a
claim in the midwest as Republicans plan
to host theirs in Milwaukee
um I'm only bringing this up because
Chicago is not only a crime-ridden city
so therefore a great spot for the DNC uh
the convention their policies made
Chicago into the hell hole that it is so
that makes you know sense but I'm also
bringing up because the DNC in Chicago
brings back to our our memory one of the
most traumatic events of the 90s that
those of you who didn't live in the 90s
uh won't remember maybe you're not aware
of but here's what happened
the last time the Democrat convention
was in Chicago watch
[Music]
I don't uh that's that's not so bad
that's actually not that's because it's
become an Infamous clip
Democrats all doing the Macarena uh
someone with a gay pride flag
um
Hillary Clinton's doing the Macarena and
I don't know you know maybe that's the
last time that any elected Democrat was
even remote retirement on second thought
uh it's it's a little
you know it's a little Charming in its
innocence I think
this was the 90s kids this is what it
was like okay we danced the Macarena and
uh you you don't you don't understand
the Macarena craze if you didn't live in
the 90s but just out of nowhere for
about six and a half weeks this dance
was everywhere people were dancing this
on they were dancing on their rooftops
they were you know they were they were
dancing at work they were like there
were traffic jams and people getting out
of their cars on the highway and doing
the the Macarena it was just everywhere
and nobody knew what was happening
nobody understood nobody knew where the
Macarena came from or why but it was
just it was there this happened a lot in
the 90s like these fads and Trends would
come in and they'd be there for six
weeks and no one knows why no one knows
why we're doing this and then we would
just stop doing it
um and it was good also the Macarena was
a good dance because it's a dance you
could dance if you didn't know how to
dance and we had those in the 90s we
weren't twerking on Tick Tock okay
we're wearing our jean shorts and we
were doing the Macarena
and then one day the Macarena went away
as quickly as it came
and we all moved on to the next Trend
which I think if I remember correctly in
chronology of this was uh I think it was
pogs pogs were the next thing you don't
understand pogs either that's the whole
thing I'm not even gonna try to explain
it it was an innocent time it was good
we were a country then we were a country
we were a nation with our pogs and our
Tamagotchis and our yo-yos
okay we can't we would there's a time
where we we would carry our yo-yos
around in our pockets
and we would be playing with the we
would you it's like our yo-yos would get
confiscated at school because all the
kids are bringing yo-yos in that was a
thing
or Blockbuster Video rentals and our
Macarena
that was a country
not not whatever this poor excuse for a
nation is now let's get to the comment
section
[Applause]
if you want a better way to simplify
your business finances across expenses
vendor payments and accounting if so
ramp could be a complete game changer
for your business ramp is a corporate
card and expense management software
designed to help you save time and money
with ramp you can issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
you can automate expense reporting so
you can stop wasting time at the end of
every month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to
the time you'll save each month on
employee expenses will allow you to
close your books eight times faster
businesses that use ramp save an average
of 3.5 percent within the first year
ramp is easy to use and get started in
less than 15 minutes whether you have
five employees or five thousand doesn't
matter and right now you can get 250
when you join Rams so just go to
ramp.com Walsh that's ramp.com Wallace
cards issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic
Bank members FDIC terms and conditions
applied
Chev says Matt I'm a 17 year old girl
was diagnosed quote-unquote with ADHD
and anxiety when I was 10 and was put on
medicine ever since after I started
listening to your show last year I asked
my psychiatrist why I never got a brain
scan and why she decided I have ADHD she
couldn't give me a valid answer so I
stopped all the meds and I went to
therapy to learn skills instead I
learned how to deal with my ADHD in a
healthy way instead of shoving it down
another thing no one talks about is that
most of the ADHD meds also shove down
your personality making you a flat
person therapy and learning skills have
been way more helpful in one year than
meds were in six thanks for speaking
about this because most people don't
well I'd love to hear that that's uh
it's a very encouraging thing for me to
hear
um that you were inspired to make that
really healthy choice I think that has
obviously worked out well for you
um and you know because that that's what
it is the the ADHD
it's a you know when I say ADHD doesn't
exist I don't mean that the the people
who are
diagnosed exist
um the behaviors that are that fall
under the ADHD umbrella those behaviors
exist those kind of Tendencies and
personality traits all those exist
I know that because I have all those
Tendencies and personality traits I
could be diagnosed ADHD in a heartbeat
if I wanted to be
uh but no thank you I'm not really
interested in taking methamphetamines
um
you know so no thanks I also just don't
it's a so these are these are behaviors
and personality traits and all that
but it's not wrong it's not disordered
it's just it's how you are and it might
make it hard in certain circumstances
and so you have to learn how to as you
say manage but really it's you know
manages one but I think I think a better
way of putting it is harness how do you
harness that
okay but my my sons my two two older
Sons uh are
could easily be diagnosed as well I mean
they're they're full of energy they
can't sit still for for anything for
very long uh all that kind of stuff
and so we think about well how can we
harness all of that energy that they
have uh the fact that they don't do as
well learning when they're sitting still
and just like regurgitating information
and trying to memorize stuff I mean you
do have to do some of that you know even
in a homeschool environment that is a
skill you have to learn so we want to
teach them that but we also think about
how can we teach them in more active
ways how can we teach them in ways that
actually work with their personality
rather than trying to suppress their
personality in order to fit it into this
you know box that we need to fit it into
for our own convenience
and uh and I think that that's just a
much better approach
uh
Nate G says I absolutely agree with not
assigning homework we homeschool our
boys and we utilize our time three to
four hours a day and no more they're
already far ahead of this kids in
schools and that's all that's needed
three of you know people
um that's one of the misconceptions
about homeschooling when you hear that
homeschool families and hear them say oh
you know we do three hours of school a
day and then
it's that's misconstrued as oh they're
not we're not really teaching them
they're not really getting an education
no it's that's all you need
and and kids that go to public school at
most they're getting three hours of
actual academic instruction at most
sometimes they don't even get that
sometimes I don't get any
but there is so much wasted time there's
so much Superfluous uh stuff that has
nothing to do with educating them
um and there's a lot of busy work and
all of that if you cut all of that out
um and he cut out things like gym class
you know you don't need gym class
because that that's the kids lives
outside of school should be gym class I
don't need my kiss like I do you think I
don't need my nine-year-old son to go 45
minutes into the gymnasium that's his
whole life he's constantly outside
running around and doing uh doing the
crowd climbing trees and building Forts
and doing all that
we don't need to schedule that into the
academic day
so cut out all that nonsense and uh and
what are you left with you're left with
you know two three four hours at most of
actual act on instruction
um
another one this is a comment from
someone with a
username in the Chinese letter so I
can't really tell you what to say but uh
Matt homework is important at school you
uh you merely learn learning alone is
not enough it's like downloading a file
and doing nothing with it you have to
spend time and do stuff on your own to
check if you actually understood what
was taught and can apply the knowledge
that is when you realize what you know
except that homework is an application
you know you're not applying it with
homework homework is is uh it is is
oftentimes it's busy work but it's
really it's just memorization and
regurgitation that's not application
that's not the same thing
and whatever you're doing with homework
you can do that at school is the point
so even if it is application there's no
reason whatever assignment they give you
for homework you can do that at school
there's no reason why you should do it
at home
uh if the schools would just utilize
that six to seven hour chunk they'd been
given which is a lot of time use the
time better
don't don't send the kids home and then
try to tell me that that I got to give
more of my time with my own child over
to you because you don't know how to do
your jobs
and you can't figure out how to educate
children when you're there when they're
there for six seven hours a day
you wanted to waste time putting movies
on for them to watch and send them to
gym class and all the rest of it and
having you know talking about diversity
and a bunch of nonsense you're wasting
time on that and then and then that's
then that's my problem as a parent now I
gotta make up for the work that you
didn't do
no
um
let's see another comment at first I was
angry about Johnny but I feel like you
gave your kids a good lesson about about
sometimes you have to put an animal down
and I'm glad you used every last piece
of them like the good Native American
that you are
Oni says more in Johnny's passing has
befits a walrus of his standing he gave
light love and joy to all even those who
didn't love him back truly the sweet
baby Gang has lost one of its best
another one we are gathered here to say
goodbye to sweet innocent stuffed soul
to a sweet innocent stuffed Soul he was
friend to all he was never afraid to put
a flipper on our shoulders and give us
Comfort if Johnny were here he would say
don't worry about me I'm in a better
place and I'm glad my presence is not
causing division in my family anymore
Rest In Pieces our beloved Johnny the
walrus
just Ray says rest in peace Johnny The
Walrus he gave us nothing but love but
this world was just too turbulent to
accept it then Aaron says
the fact that Matt just admitted to
murdering a mascot of the SPG I think he
must be punished this is a dark day for
the SPG my heart is hurting more than
ever R.I.P Johnny well I appreciate the
words you know words of sympathy and
mourning from some of you those of you
like Aaron who have tried to victim
blame me are of course all banned from
the show I should go without saying I
didn't murder Johnny Yes I chopped into
pieces my children harvested his Parts
like a black market
human organ traffickers but it was it
was
I was only doing what I had to do is it
it was a mercy killing
that's what it was Johnny it turned out
was too good for this world he was too
pure he was too generous he was too kind
and so I
and so I cut his head off and I threw
him in the trash uh that's what happened
and it's difficult to talk about it I
don't want to talk about anymore
there's a scripture from Proverbs that
says where there is no vision the people
perish and that's certainly true today
we've turned away from God not just at
our own personal expense but the expense
of society as a whole and that's what Dr
Douglas Headley points out in the latest
episode of Exodus with Jordan Peterson
check it out the vision of God is a
necessary condition of the flourishing
of society and without that Vision a
people perishes well there's there's
technical reasons for that I would say
that we know biologically now too is
that almost all enthusiasm and so that
is to be filled with the spirit of God
that's positive emotion and all positive
emotion of the of the most intense sort
I don't mean satiation and satisfaction
I mean hope and enthusiasm that moves
you forward is tied to a vision because
all positive emotion signals movement
towards a valued goal in addition to
Douglas Headley Jordan is joined by a
Roundtable group of Scholars theologians
and artists discuss one of the most
seminal books in the Bible and it says
Illuminating and thought-provoking as
you would expect new episodes are coming
online every every week and you don't
want to miss any of them but you got to
become a daily wire plus member so join
now dailywire.com subscribe to watch
Exodus now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we turn
into a sadly familiar Story one that has
played out an almost identical fashion
uh countless times on college campuses
across the country this time it's the
College of New Jersey daily y reports on
the story of a male college student who
was investigated by the school for
sexual assault
three years after a sexual encounter
that that he says was entirely
consensual reading now says the male
student Whom The Daily wire will call
John Doe was a freshman at TCNJ in the
fall of 2017 throughout the school year
a female student referred to in court
documents as Jane Rowe regularly came
over to John's dorm to spend time with
his roommate her ex-boyfriend with whom
she was still friends according to the
lawsuit John filed after uh TCNJ
punished him
he didn't interact with Jane outside of
her visits to his dorm room on September
30th 2017 not long into his freshman
year John Jane and John's roommate were
all hanging out together in John's dorm
room at some point John's roommate left
for the night and John and Jane remained
Alone Together to continue talking into
the night which Sean says turned into
consensual kissing that lasted for a few
minutes John asked Jane to to perform
oral sex on him and she agreed after
Jane voluntarily and willingly engaged
in oral sex with John the two fell
asleep in John's bed according to the
lawsuit the next morning John asked Jane
if she wanted to have sex College
teaches students that they must ask
first to engage in any kind of sexual
activity Jane agreed and the two engaged
in what John described as conceptual
sexual intercourse uh afterward Jane
left John's dorm room and from there you
know we're told that John and Jane
maintained a friendly relationship as
acquaintances acquaintances they made
small talk when they saw each other on
campus they even apparently worked on a
calculus assignment together I have no
idea how you work on a calculus how do
you do calculus with someone I don't
know I don't know how to do calculus at
all so it's a mystery to me but in any
case everything seemed fine
everything seemed normal according to
John until a month later when Jane
started dating a different guy at the
school and this is when Jane first
started telling the story of the alleged
sexual assault uh that she supposedly
suffered at the hands of John it's
nearly another year that passes
um and then finally after another year
Jane reports this alleged crime to the
school's Title IX Department
John himself was never told apparently
about the complaint and he was never
questioned he would never get a chance
to tell a side of the story he didn't
even know about it
um and then a few weeks after opening
the case Jane told the Title IX
Department that she wanted to close it
it's back to the Daily wire report
but three years later now almost four
years since the encounter Jane asked the
Title IX office to reopen her case on
May 4th 2021 Jane filed a formal
complaint against John which required
the school to notify him of the
allegations the complaint alleged that
John sexually assaulted Jane and made
sexually harassing comments to her
during the Calculus class uh in the
second trimester second semester rather
of their freshman year John was informed
that an alternative resolution agreement
ARA was being sought without telling him
the implications of such an agreement
John obtained legal counsel and was sent
the ARA which required him to perform 90
hours of community service and take
online classes John declined to accept
the ra saying that he felt it was an
unreasonable punishment for something he
didn't do according to the lawsuit since
John didn't accept ARA John Jane told
the Title IX office that she wanted to
pursue the formal resolution process
which required a hearing at this point
however John had already graduated from
TCNJ and left campus yet the school
pursued the process anyway
so now the case was fully in the hands
of the school's Kangaroo Court where all
of the the normal constitutional rights
and protections like due process which
were also you know going out the window
everywhere else too but all of that
doesn't apply
more from the report it says John's
legal counsel at the time
or at least they they act as though it
doesn't apply I should say
John's legal counsel time advised him
not to speak during the grievance
process because anything you said could
be used against him if Jane decided to
file criminal charges even though tcnj's
policies say the burden of proof is on
the school and not the accused the
school reportedly only pursued evidence
that pointed to John's guilt the school
spoke to Jane's boyfriend and her friend
who gave inconsistent statements the
school also allowed what John describes
as prejudicial hearsay statements to be
presented to the administrators
overseeing the hearing and while the
school allowed James to submit hearsay
statements regarding her mental state
John was not allowed to report her
statements or present evidence of his
own mental state John's Council at the
time also advised him not to attend the
hearing on November 5th 2021 he was
informed that he had been found
responsible would be suspended for two
years even though he didn't go to school
anymore and uh a note would appear on
his school transcript saying that he was
found responsible for sexual assault
so we're told that John obtained new
counsel and tried to get a new hearing
but he was denied and finally John filed
a lawsuit against the school as it
stands right now School tried to get the
lawsuit dismissed uh but that that
motion uh was was itself dismissed or
was denied it's not certain where this
goes from here but at least the case is
in you know a real Court
where a guy in John's situation is still
in a has a huge built-in disadvantage
it's just a slightly less huge built-in
disadvantage
now here's the point about all this two
points actually first
we don't know what really happened
between the people that were calling
John and Jane we we do know that Jane
acted every step of the way like someone
who was not actually assaulted she
waited a month to tell anybody about the
alleged incident a year to file a
complaint and she dropped it then she'd
reopened it three years later
um it doesn't seem likely that a real
victim would handle it this way and
regardless three years is just it's far
too late
to prove anything about an encounter
that occurred in a dorm room between two
people with no Witnesses
I mean no matter what actually happened
how could either of them possibly prove
anything one way or another three years
after the fact
of course in a legitimate legal setting
only the accuser has to prove something
so it's not what can either of them
prove there's only one person has to
prove anything that's the way it works
one of the most fundamental principles
of our legal system is that the accused
no matter the crime doesn't have to
prove his innocence
but these Title IX University tribunals
they don't recognize these uh principles
and they don't respect these basic human
rights a student
even a former student in this case is
presumed guilty of sexual assault the
moment he's accused of it
and and if he cannot come up with
overwhelming evidence that he didn't do
what he's accused of doing three years
ago in private in a room with the door
shut nobody else present
if you can't prove that which I don't
know how you possibly could then he'll
be branded a rapist
so the whole thing is uh I mean the
whole process that these universities go
through is a total farce it's exactly
why schools should not be in a position
of adjudicating these cases in the first
place if a crime was allegedly committed
it should be handled by the criminal
court system okay if a student if a
student is actually sexually assaulted
which obviously does happen then she's a
victim of a crime not merely a Title IX
infringement and she should go to the
police not the University Title IX
Department
second
if John was falsely accused
then then if he's falsely accused then
he's the real victim and so I don't mean
to victim blame when I say this but it
needs to be said this is yet another
reason
why casual sex is a very bad idea okay
according to his version of events which
to me seems the more credible version
he had oral sex and then intercourse
with a girl who
could barely be described as an
acquaintance
and she regretted according to his
account you know we can assume she
regretted the consensual counter later
and used it against him to try and ruin
his life
um there's not much he can do now to
fully clear his name especially when
he's in the hands of of the University
kangaroo courts
but the next potential false accusation
victim can do much to keep his life and
reputation attacked by not having casual
sex with strangers not that's not 100
foolproof guarantee you could still be
chooses something even if you were never
in the same room as somebody anyone
could accuse anyone of anything
but you certainly are putting yourself
in a much stronger position
you know it turns out there's a reason
why those prudish social conservatives
have always recommended that sex be
saved for the bonds of marriage and this
is one of those reasons sex is obviously
the most intimate and uh personal
physical interaction that you can have
with another human being if you engage
in this act with someone you don't know
someone you have no tie to no commitment
to someone you've made no promise or
vows to you have put yourself in an
incredibly vulnerable situation in many
ways this is true for the man and the
woman equally a woman who casually
engages in the reproductive act with
some random dude
could find that the ACT had exactly the
reproductive result that it is designed
to have
and now she's in the position of
carrying a child whose father she barely
knows
a man for his part could easily find
himself in the position that John is in
now if the woman decides
that she regrets the encounter and if
she has no Integrity then she could make
a false claim against him but of course
the man has no idea whether she's this
sort of woman whether she has Integrity
or not because he doesn't know her and
yet had sex with her anyway
um even if there are no false
accusations and no pregnancies and no
other consequences of that sort still
both people involved will be left with
the emotional and spiritual damage of
having given themselves physically to a
stranger they allowed themselves to be
used as an object and this I believe is
where many of the false accusations come
from
in cases of false accusations in many
cases I think
you know the woman wakes up the next
morning feels used you know
um and and she was used except that it
was it was consensual and it was Mutual
she used the man as much as he used her
that's what all casual sex is that's
what hookup culture is they were both
dehumanized and they were both
diminished by the encounter but they
participated in it if it was consensual
um
they weren't assaulted they aren't
victims
but they were harmed both of them
in ways that may or may not they they
may or may not come to understand
you know it turns out that you can
engage in something consensually and it
can still harm you it could still be bad
so this can all be avoided by simply
putting the horse in front of the cart
instead of the other way around okay
um
you know this is meant to be sex is
meant to be an expression of love
between a man and a woman who actually
love each other and are devoted and
committed to each other so
take care of the devotion and commitment
first
and then you get to the the sex and and
then you don't have to worry about
this stuff anymore
and that is why in the end after all
this it is hookup culture that we must
once again cancel
and that'll do it for uh the show today
we'll talk to you tomorrow have a great
day Godspeed foreign
[Music]
here daily wire editor-in-chief wake up
every morning with our show morning wire
where we bring you all the news that you
need to know in 15 minutes or less join
me and my co-host Georgia Howe for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire
[Music]